[Music]
okay so the umbrella academy ends on a
big
big cliffhanger that leaves a lot of
things up in the air
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down our big theories on
what the ending actually means obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
out the full season yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
if you're not already subscribed to the
channel then make sure you do
as we do videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up
if you love klaus as much as we do
anyway with all out the way
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
now let's get into our season three
theories
ok so season 2 centered around the group
traveling back in time in order to avert
the apocalypse
due to number 5 being unable to master
his abilities properly
the family would drop throughout the 60s
and the entry followed him as he tried
to reunite the group and stop bonya from
once more causing doomsday
after a couple of close calls they
managed to do this and through ben's
sacrifice
the group saved the timeline defeated
the handler and returned to the future
one day after the apocalypse however
they quickly learned that something was
off
and in the academy they not only found a
picture of ben hanging above the
fireplace
but also came across hargreaves who was
alive and well
to make matters worse he had formed the
sparrow academy
which is actually the name of the fourth
umbrella academy book
and we'll discuss how we think this
plays into it all later in the video
now i absolutely love the way the ending
shot mirrors one of the first things
that we see
in the season and though the family
prevented the apocalypse
it's clear there's gonna be a lot more
problems now though they have taken some
liberties
netflix on the whole seem to be keeping
things in line with the comics
and with season two being so close to
the second graphic novel dallas
there are some things that we can take
from this now the third volume of the
umbrella academy
hotel oblivion deals with the group
going off and doing their own things
it's not really set up here but they
could end up pulling elements across
whilst keeping the storyline sort of on
its own path
in the book there's a villain called the
murder magician who i think will
probably pop
up and also an interdimensional prison
for villains which is where the title
comes from
on the whole it's to do with the group
developing themselves
whilst the world slowly fills more and
more with superpowered lunatics
and though it's an interesting premise
i'm not sure if it's enough to build a
full season around
now these super powered people all tied
back to the 43 children that were born
on the same day and the arrival of lyla
definitely teases that there's more out
there like her so
there will be a lot more potential
students running around
and this will likely have changed the
face of the planet in several ways
that takes us to our next theory i
actually think that the original family
will all have still been born in this
timeline
but judah greaves meeting dysfunctional
versions of them in the 60s
he's decided to adopt others hogreaves
is a really stubborn dude that values
the good of the world above all else
even if it doesn't seem like he cares
all that much in the comics when the
character was questioned on why he
pushed the academy so hard
he simply stated he wanted them to be
the best versions of themselves
this pressure clearly backfired though
and i think rather than seeing the fault
in his actions
paul greaves will instead just roll the
dice with other children
and hope for a better outcome i really
think that he just decided to pick
another random seven
and as he didn't actually meet ben in
the 60s he he wouldn't have known not to
pick him
so we may even potentially see a third
season where the members of the family
end up coming face to face with versions
of themselves
that were not adopted by hargreaves as
children whilst in fiction
this normally leads to there being evil
counterparts that they must fight
i actually think that it would be
hilarious if the group met their
alternate versions
and found out they were all happy let's
face it hargreaves really put them
through the ringer
and he pretty much left them all with
severe psychological problems which
i shouldn't really be laughing at but i
do think it would be fantastic if klaus
got to meet a version of himself that
wasn't an addict and had just grown up
living a really fun lifestyle not to say
that klaus's lifestyle wasn't fun
now when it comes to dynamics klaus
probably has the most range out of all
the characters
and in my opinion this would be a really
fun angle to explore
the umbrella academy are constantly
getting kicked in the teeth
and it would add more dark humor to the
show to know how good they could have
had it
if they'd not been forced into the lives
of superheroes
that's all kind of my thoughts on how
the show could be going
but as for where the family find
themselves there's a lot we can take
from it
so as mentioned the third volume is
hotel oblivion
and the fourth is called sparrow academy
i think that netflix will
kind of just combine the two and deal
with this sparrow academy and also
elements of oblivion
that center around the hargreaves
carving out their lives
this is something that has thematically
been present throughout every season
and it almost runs through all of the
episodes of the show
for example the first season showed how
their childhood had affected them
and the lives that they'd gone on to
lead because of the actions of their
father
the second season dealt with them
carving out new identities in the past
and thus it makes sense for this to all
be brought together for a third season
that deals with them having to make new
lives in a timeline that isn't their own
i can see them being kicked out of the
academy within the opening 20 minutes of
season 3
and though hargreaves recognize them he
clearly doesn't want anything to do with
them
i think that the group landing in this
timeline we'll discover that there are
several other superpowered beings now
roaming the planet
and thus the family will have to join
with the sparrow academy in order to
take them down
or they could deal with the fact that
they're now stuck in a timeline that
isn't their own
and have to handle their new lives i
really can't see the third season
centering around them trying to fix the
timeline again as they've done this
before and it failed so
i think this change will probably be
permanent i think for the most part the
family will be stuck in this new world
dealing with the consequences of it
whilst still desperate to win the love
of their father
who now doesn't care for them in the
slightest because of all that they've
been through
they haven't really had the opportunity
to slow down and take a breather
and i think season 3 will center around
character development
and what they've actually been through
together now one of the biggest
questions you may have is
how is hargreaves alive well if you
remember in the original timeline
the entire group left him except for
pretty much luther
and thus things obviously played out
differently however
the sparrow academy are all still there
including ben
so it's likely that he lived a much
different life now that doesn't mean he
was happy though and
from the absence of pogo and grace he
probably put his all into the academy
grace of course discovered hargreaves
plans in the second season
and because of her connection to pogo
she likely took him with her
and this is why the two aren't there at
the end now though this sucks
pogo is still alive at the very least
because
it was of course vania that killed him
the last time around
who knows hargreaves may have even taken
a step back
and this is why we see ben is the leader
rather than himself
now that of course leads us into the big
elephant in the room
which is ben being alive and also
looking very emo
in the comics ben is called the horror
and i just want to bring attention to
his nickname
as it looks like without his family
around him the character ended up going
on a darker path
and yeah that hairstyle is not cool mate
it kind of gave me flashbacks to when
peter parker went all emo
and put his fringe down scary horror
horror some would say
now in the absence of vonia ben is the
most powerful of the group
he's able to summon tentacles from his
stomach and it pretty much looks like
when
goose opens its mouth in captain marvel
it completely decimates anyone that even
comes into close range with him
and because of this he's very very
dangerous
this has likely made him really arrogant
and with no one like klaus to
to stomp down his ego he's likely going
on to be
well a bit of a douche i don't know i've
never really met the guy
just the kind of vibe i get i think the
third season will be about
the academy trying to get him to come
back to the light and they'll guide him
in a new direction
all whilst right in the wrongs that
caused his death now we don't really
know what happened to ben
or the events that caused him to die so
i think that this will give the
opportunity
to the show to explore this as
everything even down to his funeral has
been teased
it opens up a wealth of possibilities as
does the other superpowered beings
that now exist on earth now holland is
of course included in this and
after gaining vania's abilities he went
into a complete meltdown that even
killed his own father
though vonya was able to stop his powers
from consuming everything around him
we did see at the end that he still
possessed certain aspects of her
abilities
this was shown by him levitating what
appeared to be a sparrow
now i've kind of went back and forth on
this in my head but i think that harlan
will likely be the first superpowered
being on earth
and that he became a hero because of
vonia's example
hargreaves may have even named the
academy after him as
he's about the right age to be someone
that grew up and made their mark
round about the time that the children
were first born so i definitely think
that he will bear heavily over this next
season
and who knows he may even end up
becoming a villain himself
as is often the case in these kinds of
shows which deal with superheroes
anyway that's our thoughts and theories
and obviously i'd love to hear yours in
the comment section below
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and if you missed our
entire season breakdown
then make sure you check it out after
this we go over all the real-life events
that inspired the season
the easter eggs things you missed and
more so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want something else to watch
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning the mcu infinity saga box set is
leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]